[Musique]
accéder aux écrits d'une civilisation
perdue déchiffrer les hiéroglyphes voilà
l'exploit de Jean-François Champollion
le plus célèbre des égyptologues c'était
en septembre 1822 il y a 200 ans
le Français Jean-François Champollion
est un être d'exception à 17 ans il
parle 12 langues son bagage linguistique
jumelait assez vastes connaissances de
l'Egypte lui permettront d'entrer dans
l'histoire
[Musique]
la pièce sur laquelle il travaille est
une copie de la Pierre de Rosette
découverte en juillet 1799 elle contient
trois séries de gravures en fait ce sont
trois versions d'un même texte le
contenu de ce dernier est d'une
incroyable richesse il est écrit en deux
langues le grec et l’égyptien ancien
mais aussi en trois écritures l'ancien
grec l'égyptien d’émotique et en
hiéroglyphe même si ce fabuleux
casse-tête est incomplet on sait que
c'est un décret une décision pour
établir le culte de polémique un pharaon
ayant vécu 200 ans avant notre ère
Champollion étudie la Pierre de Rosette
depuis 1808 il lui faudra 14 ans pour
briser son code les hiéroglyphes ne
correspondent pas à un alphabet composé
de voyelles et de consonnes il
correspondent plutôt à une combinaison
de signes idéographiques et phonétique
la clé de ce mystère sont les lignes
écrites en grec ancien une langue connue
et maîtrisée
pour la postérité Jean-François
Champollion sera associé au pharaons à
une écriture dont le sens s'est perdu
pendant près de 1400 ans